[Music]
the sense of emergency in tackling the
wildfires simply isn't mirrored by
Australia's politics scientists say the
gravity of the wildfires is directly
linked to greenhouse gases making the
planet warmer yet for nearly a decade
Australia's government has failed to
take climate change seriously this is
cold don't be afraid the 2017 and
Australia's now prime minister Scott
Morrison Lords carbon emitting fossil
fuels in Parliament showing zero
cognizance of the need for clean energy
even at a major climate conference in
Madrid just a few weeks ago Australian
delegates were accused of acting outside
the spirit of the Paris agreement
designed to limit global warming the
Australia's just kind of weren't really
planed for were they Bob Ward from the
London School of Economics was an
official observer at the Madrid
conference and witnessed the Australian
tactics firsthand Australia was trying
to insert a loophole in the rules that
would allow it to get out of doing its
full share of emissions cuts up to 2030
because it wanted credit for the fact
that these emissions have not risen
quite as much as expected by 2020
Australia's climate protestors say the
government is clamping down on climate
activism this video from a few days ago
went viral it shows a teenage girl whose
home was destroyed in the fires being
threatened with arrest for protesting
outside the Prime Minister's house if
we're truly serious about the fight
against climate change John Dee is an
environmentalist for whom campaigning
has been overtaken by survival the bush
fires are now raging within a kilometer
of his property in the Blue Mountains
many Australians around the country are
incredibly angry with the lack of action
on climate change we're seeing the
results of
right now you know here in the Blue
Mountains truly awful a truly awful day
here with the ferocity of the fire way
beyond what we're used to you know we're
getting fires that are coming earlier
more often it just feels like the whole
of Australia is on fire right now
raging fires fierce droughts and record
temperatures a perfect storm of
devastating conditions which might just
force Australian politicians to wake up
to their responsibilities on climate
change Lisa Holland Sky News